[Music]
po patterns they're more complex than
tricks and they create beautiful
pictures in midair these are some of my
favorites Drex here from Drex Factor po
sharing with you the love of Po spinning
and flow Arts to benefit your body and
brain and today I'm counting down five
of my favorite POI patterns before we
dive in I just want to give a quick
shout out to the Friends of the channel
big thanks to dark monk fire Mecca flow
fests flow toys juggling calling pyrro
Tera light toys spinballs and Ultra poy
for helping to make the videos on this
channel possible you can learn more
about all these awesome companies and
the work that they're doing to support
flow artists like yourself by checking
out the links down in the description of
this video and special thanks to the
non- business friend of the channel
Becca Becken thank you so very much for
supporting my channel my work and my
mission so what exactly is a POI pattern
I'm so glad that you asked I did a whole
video actually just a couple years ago
on the difference between POI moves
versus Po tricks versus POI patterns
that I'll go ahead and link to down in
the description as well as up in the
cards if you're watching on YouTube but
the tldr is this I think of poi patterns
as basically being compositions of Po
moves that don't necessarily fit
strictly into the jar of Po tricks that
is they aren't a unique thing that you
have to train a new skill in order to
get and also almost always they involve
a repeatable set of Po moves
that creat something that registers in
the audience that there is overall a
thing that is repeating and I know
that's kind of general and vague but
well so are many POI patterns I think
that they run the gamut of everything
from xan's Diamond to stall Chasers
personally but in this list I wanted to
focus on PO patterns that specifically
create really cool Trails when you
perform them with either light or fire
and if you'd like to see me do a
follow-up list perhaps on PO patterns
that don't necessarily create these cool
pictures things like say stall Chasers
and stacks and the like leave me a
comment and let me know and I will be
happy to hook you up all right so
without further Ado my favorite five POI
patterns let's let them
roll number one
ccaps all right all right so this one is
definitely a gimme but I mean we kind of
get the word patterns when it comes to
PO patterns from the whole theory that
gave birth to caps they are after all
continuous assembly patterns so I mean
it it kind of a given that they're going
to wind up on this list po caps
specifically come out of a series of
moves that UDA imamura was demonstrating
in a series of videos more than a decade
ago a French po Spinner by the name of
Damen boy bouier did an analysis thread
on the home of poy forums in which he
analyzed this movement and christened it
the first of an entirely new category of
poi patterns called caps and perhaps no
poy pattern is as ubiquitous as that
initial C cap that Damen pulled out of
that Udi imora video more than a decade
ago go and it's easy to see why this has
become such a Mainstay of the PO
spinning World such to the point that I
think most people think of this as a
discreet trick in of itself not just a
pattern it's relatively easy to teach to
people the movements in it are
relatively easy to describe and of
course the pattern looks beautiful so if
you haven't already learned them I do
have a tutorial on ccaps that I'll go
ahead and link to down in the
description as well as up in the cards
number two pendulum versus
trra Okay so this one takes a little bit
of explanation and God only knows I have
had many moments when I have been old
man yells at clad when it comes to this
move see that Tri cetra isn't actually a
tri ketra it's a cap it takes the top
half of a linear isolation and cuts and
past it together with the bottom half of
a box mode for pedal anti-spin flower
the placement of the pedals doesn't
match up and quite frankly it doesn't
even remotely look like the ancient
Celtic knotwork pattern that we get the
word Tri ketra from and yes in the grand
scheme of things it doesn't matter what
we call it and I am happy to continue
you're calling it a tri ketra but
because it is a cap I do think that it
belongs on a list of awesome POI
patterns and of course it does have to
be said that that pendulum we're teaming
it up with could technically be
considered a cap to one half of an
extension and one half of a horizontal
linear isolation but I think ruining
your childhood by breaking that Tri
ketra out of its old box is probably
enough work for one day for me and if
you think my definition of a POI pattern
is a little bit too loose with this one
well you're going to love the next one
number three static spin versus
pentagram yeah okay so there is no part
of this that I can even remotely claim
to be a cap and that's okay because in
my mind this qualifies as a POI pattern
because it takes multiple hand paths to
be able to create the complete trick
it's a funny pattern of pentagrams that
it takes performing The Hand path twice
in a row in order to be able to trace
out the full trick this means of course
that you wind up with two repetitions of
that static spin in the middle now
overall yes it does take a while to
complete the pattern but I think that's
true of pretty much every single trick
on this list and granted this isn't one
that I bust out that frequently if for
no other reason then yeah the fact that
it takes so long for the pattern to
fully register with the viewer is kind
of a problem unless of course it's dark
and we're dealing with LEDs or fire but
hey that's exactly the theme of this
list so it fits and if you want an extra
special challenge with this one you can
always switch from doing a static spin
down to an isolation which means that
that pentagram winds up working inside a
hand path that is the same size as a cat
eye you can think of this as basically
going back and forth between a vertical
cat eye and a horizontal cat eye with
you know just a little bit of wiggle
room there and speaking of poi patterns
that take way too long to register with
the audience we
have number four the eight-step
cap so I will confess that this move has
always driven me crazy because it takes
so bloody long to complete and because I
always get confused as to which section
of the cap I'm supposed to be doing next
but it is also undeniable that the
eight-step cap has had a massive impact
on the Techo world first conceived of by
Charlie Cushing as he was working on his
n Square Theory this had the added
benefit that it allowed for easy
transitions back and forth between
different timing and Direction modes you
can go back and forth between together
time and split time relatively easily
using this pattern of course it just
happened to be a happy accident that it
created an awesome pattern that looked
cool in its own right and of course many
people myself included have done this
wrong in many ways over the years and
done too many repetitions of the cap in
different spots and that's okay I think
like the repeating idea of doing a cap
across one side and then the next side
and the next side and the next side
incrementally around the circle is
really the core idea here even if it
winds up say being 16 steps instead of
eight and for all my belly aching I do
have to admit that this is a great brain
exercise it requires you to keep track
of which quadrant you're doing the cap
in at any given point and also which
hand is going to be performing anti-
spinner extension for an extra quarter
of the circle yeah you know as much as I
dislike it it's probably because this
requires more brain power than I
normally want to expend on a pattern
like this and that's not always a bad
thing awesome so before I reveal to you
the final trick on this list I do have a
favor to ask if you come this far it
probably means that you're super into
pyric and patterns and guess what I
produce regular videos on those topics
so if you wouldn't mind subscribing to
the channel it would mean that you would
get to see every video that I upload as
soon as I upload it helps you out it
helps the channel out everybody wins so
go do that please and thank you and now
for my final pick for my top five
favorite po
patterns number five xan's
Diamond okay so seriously who didn't see
this one coming I will always have a
soft spot in my heart for this PO trick
not only is it something that I kind of
accidentally stumbled into as I was
playing around with breaking up the
Mercedes into various different pieces
but it was also one of those tricks that
was considered one of the hardest things
that you could do with POI when I was
starting out and when I got it I really
felt like ID arrived as a tech poy
spinner it also just clicks off all of
the checks on the list here you know it
takes a while to render it still appears
as a repeating pattern to the audience
and of course it leaves behind beautiful
Trails I will confess that this is a
trick that I still bust out constantly
to this day and I'm constantly trying to
find new ways to reinterpret and bring
into my pois spinning and all kinds of
cool ways the ultimate irony of this
trick of course is that xan did not
Discover it and remains perplexed to
this day how it got associated with his
name but you know what I think that
actually works in its favor because it
means that we have this as a discreet po
trick and pattern that we hold on to
there are so many other po patterns that
have been thrown out there into the
world over the years years and that
people forget simply because they never
had a name attached to them xan's
diamond is also the backbone of one of
my favorite po workshops to teach one
that involves teaching people no matter
how long they've been spinning how to
put together discret bits of movement
into more complicated ones and I have to
say after more than a decade of seeing
people at all different stages of their
po Journey perform xan's diamond for the
first time and feeling really good about
it there's no feeling like that in the
world and that is why it is my number
one pick for my favorite POI pattern of
all time what did you think of my picks
did I leave out any POI patterns that
you think should have been on this list
would you like to see a followup on some
poy patterns that don't necessarily
produce those interesting Trails leave
me a comment and let me
[Music]
know this video would not be possible
without the kind support of all of these
awesome people right here these are my
flow patrons over on patreon they and
the people listed down in the
description help to make this video and
all the videos on this channel possible
thank you one and all for your very
generous support and if you out there
watching would like to become a
supporter and you're not currently you
can do that by heading on over to
patreon.com factor poo and signing up
there you can get access to a whole
bunch of awesome rewards but even better
than that you'll be helping me out in my
mission to bring po in flow Arts to the
whole wide world so go check that out
please and thank you and if you'd like
to check out more list videos that I've
done ticking off my top five favorite
different py tricks in different
categories I will go ahead and leave a
link to a playlist of those videos down
in the description as well as up on
screen if you're watching this video on
YouTube thanks so much for watching make
sure to get out and flow today and I'll
see you with a new video real soon take
care now peace